j'ai trouvé ça ou dans un carton c'était
aux gens qui habitaient là avant
christie concentrez vous bien qu'est ce
qu'il ya il faut qu'on trouve les autres
cassette minecraft que meilleur
franchement il se passe des choses
étranges et si fier c'est bizarre
je vois quelque chose quand je regarde
dans la caméra j'ai entendu parler
d'esprit sur des photos mais perso j'en
ai jamais vu qu'est ce que tu fais là
dedans qu'est ce qu'elle dira pas
lambert dit bloody mary je sais pas ce
qui se passe mais ça a un rapport avec
les cassettes
c'est la première fois qu'il dessine
quelque chose comme ça évidemment hervé
criqui toby et si quelqu'un avait tout
fait pour qu'on s'installe dans cette
maison il n'y a pas de coïncidence
je crois qu'elle fait partie d'une
prophétie
normal activitistes un gosse dimension
mike ait quelque chose derrière toi le
cinéma le 21 octobre